here begineth the treaties of the
boyhood of jesus according to thomas
when jesus was five years old he took of
the clay of a fish pond and made of it
twelve sparrows and it was the sabbath
when jesus did this amongst the boys of
the jews and the boys of the jews went
away and said to joseph his father
behold thy son was playing along with us
and he took clay and made sparrows which
it was not lawful to do on the sabbath
and he has broken it and joseph went
along to the boy jesus and said to him
why hast thou done this
and jesus opened his hands and ordered
the sparrows saying go up into the air
and fly nobody shall kill you
but a pharisee who was with jesus took
an olive branch and began to let the
water out of the fountain which jesus
had made and when jesus saw this he said
to him in a rage thou in pious and
ignorant sodomite what harm have my
works the fountains of water done thee
behold thou shalt become like a dry tree
having neither roots nor leaves nor
fruit
and immediately he dried up and fell to
the ground
and died
and his parents took him away dead and
reproached joseph saying
see what thy son has done
teach him to pray not to
blaspheme and a few days after as jesus
was walking through the town with joseph
one of the children ran up and struck
jesus on the arm and jesus said to him
so thou shalt not finish thy journey and
immediately he fell to the ground and
died and those who saw these wonderful
things cried out to joseph it is not
right for such a boy to be among us
and joseph went and brought him and they
said to him go away from this place but
if thou must live with us teach him to
pray and not to blaspheme our children
have been killed joseph called jesus and
reproved him saying why does thou
blaspheme for these people who live here
hate us
and jesus said i know that these words
are not mine but thine but i will hold
my tongue for thy sake and let them see
to it in their wisdom and immediately
those who were speaking against jesus
became blind and joseph seeing what
jesus had done in a fury seized him by
the ear and jesus said to joseph in
anger it is enough for thee to see me
not to touch me for thou knowest not who
i am but if thou didst know that would
not make me angry and although just now
i am with thee i was made before thee
one day when jesus was climbing on a
certain house along with the children he
began to play with them and one of the
boys fell down through a back door and
died immediately
and when the children saw this they all
ran away but jesus remained in the house
and when the parents of the boy who had
died had come they spoke against jesus
surely it was him that made him fall
down and they reviled him and jesus
coming down from the house stood over
the dead child and with a loud voice
called out the name of the child
sinu
[Music]
rise and say whether it was i that made
thee fall down
and suddenly he rose up and said
no my lord
and his parents seeing such a great
miracle done by jesus glorified god and
adored jesus
and joseph seeing that he had such favor
and that he was increasing in stature
thought it right to take him to learn
his letters and he handed him over to
another teacher to be taught but jesus
was silent and made him no answer
jesus said to the master if thou art
indeed a master and if indeed thou
knowest the letters tell me the power of
the a and i shall tell thee the power of
the bee then his master was filled with
fury and struck him on the head
and jesus was angry and cursed him and
suddenly he fell down and died
and jesus returned home and joseph gave
orders to mary his mother not to let him
go out of the court of the house
and jesus himself turned unto the jews
and said to them now let all them that
see not see and let them understand
which understand not and let the deaf
hear and let them arise which have died
by my needs and when the child jesus
ceased speaking all the afflicted were
made whole as many as had been afflicted
by his word and they durst not speak to
him and no man after that dost provoke
him lest he should curse him and he
should be made
when did jesus get his beard early roman
images of jesus portray him as clean
shaven but imagery quickly adopted the
bearded look facial hair has gone in and
out of fashion for millennia but having
a nice clean shave definitely feels and
looks great henson razors have been kind
enough to support this video and their
razors are the best on the market in
2020 henson switched from making
aerospace parts including for the actual
international space station and took
that precision expertise and need for
perfection into the world of razors
these are space racers and they feel
great in fact they've convinced me to
switch from using my terrible electric
razor and i feel much better for it it's
a nice habit to get into and a great
refreshing way to start the day they're
also totally plastic free and should
last for decades and in the long term
because they basically never break they
should save you loads of money also the
blades are only 10 cents and you can get
them easily on amazon meaning that it's
barely five dollars a year to maintain
click on the link in the description to
get 100 free blades with the purchase of
a razor and start having a nice smooth
face thanks to henson for supporting
history content on youtube
[Music]
and joseph rose up and said to anas and
caiaphas truly and well do you wonder
since you have heard that jesus has been
seen alive from the dead but it is more
to be wondered at that he is not the
only one who has risen from the dead and
hear me now for we all know the blessed
simon the great priest and simon himself
had two sons
go therefore and see their tombs for
they are open because they
have risen
and indeed they are as silent as the
dead but come let us go to them let us
conduct them to us with all honor and
respect perhaps they will speak to us of
the mystery of the resurrection
walking into the city of arimathea they
found them there on their bended knees
and spending their time in prayer they
said do you believe that it was jesus
who raised you from the dead tell us how
you have risen from the dead
hearing this adoration they trembled in
their body and groaned being disturbed
in heart and together they looked
towards heaven and with their fingers
made the sign of the cross on their
tongues and immediately they spoke
together saying give each of us sheets
of paper and let us write what we have
seen and heard and they gave it to them
and they sat down and each of them wrote
saying
when we were along with our fathers
lying in the deep in the blackness of
darkness suddenly there appeared a
golden heat of the sun and immediately
the father of all the human race with
all the patriarchs and prophets exalted
saying that light is the source of
eternal light now it has come and shone
upon us sitting in death
and when all the saints were exalting lo
satan the prince and leader of death
said to hades make thyself ready to
receive jesus who boasts himself to be
the son of god and is a man fearing
death and he has withstood me much doing
me evil and many whom i made blind lame
death leprous and demonic he has healed
with a word and those whom i have
brought to thee dead he has dragged away
from thee
hades answering said to prince satan who
is he that is so powerful when he is a
man in fear of death for all the
powerful of the earth are kept in
subjection by my power if then thou art
powerful what is that man jesus like who
though fearing death withstands thy
power
and as prince satan and hades were thus
speaking to each other in turn suddenly
there was a voice as of thunders and a
shouting of spirits lift up your gates
ye princes and be ye lifted up ye
everlasting gates and the king of glory
shall come in
and all the multitude of the saints
hearing this said to hades with the
voice of reproach
open thy gates that the king of glory
may come in
when this was seen by hades and death
and their impious officers along with
their cruel servants they trembled at
perceiving in their own dominions the
clearness of so greater light when they
saw christ suddenly in their abodes and
they cried out saying we have been
overcome by thee
who art thou
then the king of glory trampling on
death by his majesty and seizing prince
satan delivered him to the power of
hades
and drew adam to his brightness
these are the divine and sacred
mysteries which we saw and heard more we
are not allowed to tell other than the
mysteries of god as michael the
archangel adjured us and said you shall
go into jerusalem with your brethren and
continue in prayers and with none of the
men shall you speak and you shall sit as
if dumb until the hour shall come when
the lord himself shall permit you to
relate the mysteries of his divinity
this is the secret message of judgment
jesus spoke with judas iscariot over a
period of eight days three days before
he celebrated passover
one day he was with his disciples in
judea he found them sitting together
practicing their piety when he came up
to his disciples sitting together
praying over the bread he laughed the
disciples said to him master why are you
laughing at our prayer
what have we done
this is what's right he answered and
said to them i'm not laughing at you
you're not doing this because you want
to but because through this your god
will be praised they said master you are
the son of our god jesus said to them
how do you know me truly i say to you no
generation of the people among you will
know me when his disciples heard this
they started to get angry and furious
and started to curse him in their hearts
but when jesus noticed their ignorance
he said to them if any of you is strong
enough among humans to bring out the
perfect humanity stand up and face me
all of them said we're strong enough but
their spirits weren't brave enough to
stand before him except judas is scarier
he was able to stand before him but he
couldn't look him in the eye so he
looked away judas said to him i know who
you are and where you're from i'm not
worthy to utter the name of the one who
has sent you then jesus knowing that he
was thinking about what's exalted said
to him come away from the others and
i'll tell you the mysteries of the
kingdom
jesus said the souls of every human
generation will die however when these
people have completed their time in the
kingdom and the spirit leaves them their
bodies will die but their souls will
live and they'll be taken up judas said
what will the rest of the human
generations do jesus said it's not
possible to sow on rock and harvest its
fruit in the same way it's not possible
to sow on the defiled race along with
the perishable wisdom and the hand which
created mortal humans so that their
souls may go up to the realms above
truly i say to you no ruler angel or
power will be able to see the places
that this great holy generation will see
jesus said come and i'll teach you about
the mysteries that no human will see
because there exists a great and
boundless realm whose horizons no
angelic generation has seen in which a
great invisible spirit which no angelic
eye has ever seen no heart has ever
comprehended and it's never been called
by any name
and a luminous cloud appeared there and
the spirit said let an angel come into
being to attend me
judas said to jesus
does the human spirit die
jesus said this is how it is god
commanded michael to loan spirits to
people so that they might serve
then the great one commanded gabriel to
give spirits to the great generation
with no king
the spirit along with the soul then god
caused knowledge to be brought to adam
and those with him so that the kings of
chaos and hades might not rule over them
then judas said to jesus what will those
do who you've baptized in your name
jesus said truly i say to you this
baptism which they've received in my
name will destroy the whole generation
of the earthly adam tomorrow they'll
torture the one who bears me but you'll
do more than all of them because you'll
sacrifice the human who bears me your
horn has already been raised your anger
has been kindled your star has ascended
and your heart has strayed
look you've been told everything lift up
your eyes and see the cloud with the
light in it and the stars around it
and the star that leads the way
is your star
then judas looked up and saw the
luminous cloud
and he entered it and judas didn't see
jesus anymore
some scribes were there watching closely
so they could arrest him during his
prayer because they were afraid of the
people since they all regarded him as a
prophet and they approached judas and
said to him what are you doing here
aren't you jesus's disciple then he
answered them as they wished then judas
received some money and handed him over
to them
in the consulate of theodosius augustus
the younger a certain honorable young
man then dwelling at tarsus in the house
which had been the house of saint paul
an angel appeared unto him by night and
gave him a revelation
saying that he should break up the
foundation of the house and publish that
which he found
and he dug and found a box of marble
inscribed upon the sides therein was the
revelation of saint paul and there was
written therein as follows
the angels said unto me follow me and i
will show thee the place of the
righteous where they are taken when they
are dead and thereafter will i take thee
to the bottomless pit and show thee the
souls of the sinners into what manner of
place they are taken when they are dead
[Music]
i went with the angel of the lord and
looked before me and saw a place through
which passed thousands and thousands and
myriads and myriads of angels whose
faces were as of panthers and their
teeth stuck forth out of their mouth and
their eyes were bloodshot and their hair
loose like woman's hair and burning
scorches were in their hands
i feared and asked who are these
the angel answered these are the
ministers of the whole creation which
come unto the souls of the ungodly and
take them and lay them down here they
fly three days with them in the air
before they take them and cast them into
the everlasting torment after i looked
into the height and beheld other angels
whose faces shone like the sun and their
loins were girt with golden girdles
holding palms in their hands and the
sign of god full of all gentleness and
mercy and i asked the angel and said who
are these lord that are of so great
beauty and compassion and the angel
answered and said unto me these are the
angels of righteousness that are sent to
bring the souls of the righteous in the
hour of necessity and i said unto the
angel i would see the souls of the
righteous and of the sinners as they
depart out of the world and the angel
answered and said unto me look down upon
the earth and i looked and i saw a great
cloud of fire spread over the whole
world
and i sighed and i wept
and the angel said hast thou perceived
all these things and i said yes lord and
he said unto me follow me again and i
will take thee and show thee the places
of the righteous and he brought me down
from the third heaven and led me into
the second heaven and from the firmament
he led me unto the gates of heaven and i
looked around that land and saw a river
flowing with milk and honey and the
trees were full of fruits from the root
even to the upper branches and there
were ten thousand dates in each cluster
and he said unto me come follow me and i
will show thee the souls of the ungodly
and the sinners that thou mayest know
what manner of place they have
and i saw there a river of fire burning
with heat and in it was a multitude of
men and women sunk up to their knees and
other men up to the navel others also up
to the lips and others up to the hair
and i asked the angel and said
lord who are these that are sunk up to
their knees in the fire he answered and
said unto me these are they which when
they come out of the church occupy
themselves in disputing with idle talk
but these that are sunk up to the navel
are they who when they have received the
body and blood of christ go and commit
fornication and do not cease from their
sins until they died
and they that are sunk up to their lips
are they that slandered one another when
they gathered in the church of god but
those that are sunk up to their eyebrows
are they that beckon to one another and
privately devise evil against their
neighbors and i saw another man in the
river of fire sunk up to his knees and
his hands were stretched out and bloody
and worms issued out of his mouth and
nostrils and he was groaning and
lamenting and crying out and said have
mercy on me for i suffer hurt more than
the rest that are in this torment and i
asked who is this lord and he said unto
me
this whom thou seest was a deacon who
devoured the offerings and committed
fornication and did not write in the
sight of god
therefore without ceasing he payeth the
penalty
and i looked and saw beside him another
man and the angel over him having a
great razor red hot and therewith he cut
the lips of that man and the tongue
likewise and i sighed and i wept and i
asked
who is this man lord
and he said to me this that thou seest
was a reader and read unto the people
but he kept not the commandments of god
now also he path his own penalty
and again i beheld their men and women
with their hands and feet cut off and
naked in a place of ice and snow and
worms devoured them and when i saw it i
wept and asked who are these lord and he
said unto me these are they that injured
the fatherless and widows and the poor
and trusted not in the lord and
thereafter i saw men and women clad in
rags full of pitch and brimstone of fire
and there were dragons twined about
their necks and shoulders and feet and
angels having horns of fire constrained
them and smote them and closed up their
nostrils
and i sighed and i wept and said
woe unto men
woe unto the sinners and i asked and i
said lord who are they that are in this
place
and he said unto me these are they which
say that christ rose not from the dead
and that this flesh riseth not again and
i inquired and said
lord is there no fire or heat in this
place
and he said unto me
in this place is nothing else but cold
and snow
[Music]
and thereafter i saw the son of god
coming down out of heaven and on his
head was a crown and when they that were
in torment saw him they all cried out
with one voice saying
have mercy upon us o exalted son of god
and the son of god said what good works
have ye done that ye should ask of me
refreshment
my blood was shed for you and not even
so did ye repent for your sake i bear a
crown of thorns on mine head for you i
received buffets upon my cheeks and not
even so did ye repent yet now because of
michael the archangel of my covenant and
the angels that are with him and because
of paul my dearly beloved and because of
your brethren that are in the world and
do offer oblations and because of your
sons for in them are my commandments and
yet more because of mine own goodness on
that day whereon i rose from the dead i
grant unto all of you that are in
torment refreshment for a day and a
night
forever
and all there cried out and said we
bless thee o son of god for that thou
hast granted us rest for a day and a
night
and as they thus spake the angels of
torment and the evil angels were wrathed
with them and said how long have ye wept
inside and yet have ye received this
great grace even refreshment for the
night and day of the lord's day because
of paul the dearly beloved of god who
hath come down unto you and after these
things the angel said unto me hast thou
seen all these things and i said yes
lord
[Music]
you